it's Monday September 12th and you got
me Rob unfortunately Mary and Jess are
out that's okay because I got some hot
news come your way tie in fall to is
just around the corner and if you're
wondering where all those hot burn cards
went from the previous game I think I
found him and a bingo was his name-o it
appears all those missing burn cards
have taken form in an upcoming mobile
game titanfall frontline similar to
hearthstone it's a free strategy card
game with vs. multiplayer set for
release on iOS and Android this fall
publisher nexon has revealed this deck
building game will feature hundreds of
pilots Titans and special ability burn
cards players can customize and upgrade
their decks to their own player styles
such as a quick damage dealing method
with fast pilots and Titans with a
strong defensive technique with
appropriate units installations and
support personnel again you can expect
time for frontline to release sometime
this fall if you've been on the fence
about purchasing an Xbox one s this new
bundle just might float your boat well
three bundles actually Microsoft has
announced today the xbox one s
battlefield one special edition bundles
the first bundle comes out october 21st
it includes a standard white 500
gigabyte system with a copy of
battlefield one that'll set you back
three hundred dollars the second bundle
is the same only it has a storm gray
finish however it comes out one week
later and is exclusive to Microsoft
stores and walmart the final bundle
announces the big one the one terabyte
Xbox one s comes in a military green
design with matching controller a
digital copy of early and lister deluxe
edition of BF one it includes the
lawrence of arabia pack and new visual
appearances for behemoth vehicles
that'll set you back three hundred and
fifty dollars and comes out october 18th
what was also revealed in the video
announcement is that battlefield one
will add support for high dynamic range
aka HDR for the Xbox one s via online
patch this isn't too big of a surprise
given that at sony's playstation meeting
last week battlefield HDR support would
be available for the playstation 4 pro
if you were hoping to play The Last
Guardian this October well you know
what's coming on the playstation blog
today Sony Computer Entertainment
worldwide studios president Shuhei
Yoshida stated the Last Guardian will be
now released on december six you she
explained a delay as a difficult
decision particularly with this game but
we have encountered more bugs than
anticipated while in the final stages of
development to ensure that the Last
Guardian delivers on the experience the
game's creators have envisioned we need
to take the extra time to work on those
issues it's been quite a ride for the
Last Guardian over the years since the
game was originally revealed in 2009 as
a ps3 title but then again a few more
weeks ain't too bad right well that's it
for me thank God right well time to
start that timer and count to 24 hours
because tomorrow you'll be getting me
again
you